my name is a concussion and I'm a senior
in electrical engineering and computer
science so my the goal of my project was
to use capnography to diagnose between
two cardio respiratory conditions
congestive heart failure and chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease so the
problem is that there's a lot of people
suffering from respiratory conditions
however the diagnostic tests that are
used to diagnose these conditions
require a lot of effort from the patient
and they might be very hard to comply
with if the patient is under a lot of
distress so what we want to do is
replace these tests with capnography
which is effort independent and very
easy to comply with so capnography
measures the partial pressure of carbon
dioxide in exhaled breath as the patient
is breathing normally and produces a
graph called a capnogram and these
capnogram have distinct shapes for
different cardio respiratory conditions
so the first step is to produce a
mechanistic model that is based on the
compartmental models of the respiratory
system that produces an expression for
the partial pressure of carbon dioxide
or the capnogram as a function of
respiratory parameters and these
respiratory parameters are
physiologically relevant so the first
step is to pre-process our capnogram to
extract the portions of the capnogram
corresponding to exhalation and then fit
our mechanistic model to these
accelerations to extract these
respiratory parameters and use these
respiratory parameters to actually
diagnose between the two conditions
so using these estimated parameters in a
training set we train a quadratic
discriminator and we use this quadratic
discriminator on a test set and applied
it on a patient by patient basis to
obtain an accuracy of around eighty
seven point five percent which was very
successful